- Good afternoon everybody.
I'm Gary Tomlinson,
the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center.
Not for much longer, the incoming director
is Alice Kaplan
and she is right down there.
(laughing)
Couldn't resist pointing that out Alice.
But I want to welcome you
to the Finzi-Contini lecture
for this semester by
distinguished journalist
and writer Philippe Lancon,
it promises to be a wonderful
and inspirational presentation.
Before I turn the podium over
to the introducer of our speaker,
we do this seriatim,
I'd like to say a few preliminary words.
The Finzi-Contini lectureship
was endowed in 1990
by the honorable Guido Calabresi,
judge of the U.S. Court of
Appeal for the Second Circuit
and former Dean of the Yale Law School
and his brother, Doctor Paul Calabresi
in memory of their mother,
Bianca Maria Finzi-Contini Calabresi.
She was a scholar of European literature
and a native of Ferrara.
She fled fascism in Italy
along with her husband,
Doctor Massimo Calabresi
and settled here in New Haven.
Guido Calabresi just
presented me a moment ago
with a photograph.
He's about five years
old in the photograph
and there they are in New Haven already.
It's an extraordinary photograph.
The whole family with Bianca Maria
up at the top of the steps.
In any case she was a scholar
of European literature
native of the Ferrara.
They settled here in New Haven,
she earned a PhD in French at Yale
with a dissertation on French
and Breton historian Ernest Renan.
She became professor of French and Italian
at Connecticut College,
then was for many years
professor and chair
of the Department of Italian
at Albertus Magnus College.
She died in 1982 at the age of 80.
Guido Calabresi and his
wife Ann are here today.
They're right down here in the second row
and I'd like you to
join me in thanking them
and their family for their generosity.
(crowd applauding)
They remain extraordinarily
engaged and busy busy people
and it's always wonderful to see them here
in the Whitney Humanities Center audience.
After the lecture there will
be a reception in room 108
which is straight down
the hall behind you.
Most of you know where that
reception room is already.
You're all invited to it. Please do come.
And last but not least,
I'm directed by Yale legal counsel
to read the following paragraph.
Our events may be recorded
or live streamed or photographed
for educational, archival
or promotional purposes
including use in print on the internet
and in other forms of media.
All attendees and participants
or parents or guardians of
minors attending the event agree
by virtue of their attending the event
or otherwise participating in the event
to the possibility of their voices
or likenesses being
captured by these means
and used for such purposes
without compensation to them.
And they hereby waive any
related right of privacy
or publicity.
Such as the world we live in.
That's not part of the announcement
but in any case, yes
you are duly announced.
(giggles)
Introducing Philippe Lancon
today will be Morgane Cadieu,
assistant professor of French here at Yale
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
to the podium Professor Cadieu
(audience applauding)
- Good afternoon.
Welcome to the 2020 Finzi-Contini lecture
and thank you very much
for adding this conference
to your schedule.
So my name is Morgane Cadieu.
I'm an associate professor
in the Department of French,
specializing in contemporary fiction
and experimental literature.
I'd like to start by thanking
the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center,
Gary Tomlinson
and the chair of the
department of French Alice Kaplan
for making this even possible
and for giving me the honor
of introducing our guest this afternoon.
We're delighted to welcome Phillip Lancon,
a French writer, journalist
and cultural critic
specialized in French and
Latin American literatures.
He studied at Duke University
and lectured at Princeton
University on literature,
culture society and violence.
Named the Chevalier du le
Ordre des Arts et des Lettres
by the French government,
he's also the 2012 recipient of the
(speaking foreign language)
from the French Academy,
a prize aimed at supporting
literary creation.
In 2013, he was recognized
with the Jean-Luc Lagardere Award
for journalist of the year.
He writes for the daily
newspaper Liberation,
the magazine Vontielle
and for the satirical weekly
newspaper, Charlie Hebdo.
In January 7, 2015
Philippe Lancon was seriously wounded
during the terrorist attack perpetrated
against Charlie Hebdo.
A shooting that killed 12 persons
and wounded 11.
He spent nine months in
the Parisian hospitals,
Le pitie Salpetriere and Les Invalides,
the great monument which still serves
as a hospital for veterans.
His memoir Le Lambeau,
published by Gallimard in 2018
recounts the attack
but his first and foremost is a narrative
about the body,
about how the event
and injuries affected
the author's relationship
to his parents, friends and lovers.
But also to painting music and literature.
It's a book about what it means
to be guarded by police officers 24 seven,
a hospital diary
and the split between the patient
and what the author calls l'homme d'avan,
the man from before.
The narrator of Le Lambeau
details his new experience of space
which he calls the grammar
of the hospital room.
I quote,
"Those who entered the room had out sided
"less existence than
characters in the novel
"once the book was closed."
end of quote.
Le Lambeau is also reflection on time.
Although the narrator is an
avid reader of Marcel Proust,
he explicitly rejects the
expression, "time regained"
which is the title of the last volume
of À la recherche du temps perdu
To capture the singularity of his recovery
he favors expressions such as,
time interrupted,
mixed time and suspended time.
In the aftermath of the 2015 attack,
many started to use the slogan
(speaking in foreign language)
notably during demonstrations
against terrorism
and for the freedom of the press.
Philippe Lancon was in
the hospital at the time
and was as he explains it,
not charlie but Chloe.
Le Lambeau, he writes Jessie Chloe
which is the first name of his surgeon
Doctor Chloe Bertolus,
head of the Maxillofacial Surgery Service
at the Pitie Lepetriere and
a key character in his book.
The French title Le Lambeau
refers to a specific type
of reconstructive surgery
called the fibula flap.
In French Le Lambeau also means a bit,
a scrap, a shred
or a tatter.
Last fall Europa editions
published the English version
of Le Lambeau translated
by Stephen Randall
as Disturbance, Surviving Charlie Hebdo.
Le Lambeau is a best-seller
anonymously acclaimed
by critics and the winner of many prizes
the Prix Feemina, the Prix du Roman News,
the Jury's special selection
of the Prix Renaudot,
(speaks in foreign language)
awarded yearly
to both the Latin american writer
and to a French writer.
Le Lambeau was named Best Book of the Year
by the magazine's Lire
and Les Inrockuptibles.
Philippe Lancon is also
the author of two novels,
Lis iles in 2011,
the islands of the title
be Hong Kong in Cuba
and L'Elan on the urge
or the impetus in English in 2013
centered on
(mumbles)
And one can not is that
his writings all rhyme.
Les iles, L'Elan, Le Lambeau.
His lecture today starts with a question,
"Did I write a feel-good book?"
So, please welcome our guest
Philip Lancon very warmly.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you. Good evening.
Thank you to be here.
So,
as my title is,
"Did I write a feel-good book?"
And the purpose of this
little conference is
to answer it or not to answer it.
Before Christmas,
a French literary magazine asks me
to draw up a list of my
favorite feel-good books.
Obviously I was not the only writer
whom the magazine asked to do this.
It was to be part of a
feature on feel-good books.
When the end-of-the-year
holidays approach,
everything becomes depressing.
And we want everyone to be happy.
So we give them chocolate
or feel-good books.
Sometimes we obtain a result opposite
to the one we were hoping for.
Indigestion in the case of chocolates
and the Blues in the
case of feel-good books.
Maybe that's what we were after.
We don't necessarily like the people
to whom we think we are
obliged to give presents
or we don't like them well
giving them the gifts that
we would like to receive.
The problem is that
even aside from the question of taste,
we are never in their shoes.
I suppose some writers would have liked
to put their own books
at the top of the list
but of course no one did that.
Also writers are almost always convinced
that they are talent,
they know how to find
modesty when they have to.
However,
I said to myself,
"Would they really have wanted their books
"to be at the top of
the list they drew up?"
I don't know many writers would feel proud
of having written a feel-good book.
It would seem to most of them
that they were acting like priests,
psychotherapists,
or simply charlatans.
In one in one way or another,
a writer claims to be talking
about what people experience,
think and feel.
This reality isn't intended
to make us feel good.
It isn't intended for anything
either good or bad.
It is content to be born, grow
and flow in every way possible like water.
Sometimes our imagination gives it
banks, dikes or dams
but it immediately overflows them.
Often this reality circulates in a hole.
We were peacefully
skating on a frozen lake
looking out of the sky
like a heroine in a Russian novel
or a little figure in a Bragger painting.
Suddenly, the ice cracks
and we fall into the hole.
This was not foreseen.
That's what happened to me.
Below the water is cold
and you can't see anything.
At the very bottom there are huge monsters
that never see the light of day.
You would touch them,
you feel them,
you fear them,
you don't tame them.
You don't know exactly
what they look like.
But it's possible to
describe the perceptions,
sensations
and feelings
that they elicit in us.
That they impose on us.
As a reader,
I initially found the
magazine requests ridiculous.
But since I'm a journalist,
I wasn't surprised
because I know how most
periodicals operate.
They love to make lists and reward prizes
especially as I have said,
at the end of the year.
You would think their editors
had never left school.
I imagine they must
have been model students
or they want to think their readers we're
like them model students.
The ones who were rewarded in my time
at least with fine books
at the end of the year.
Even if the reports in the newspaper
become the lives of losers,
the lives of those will
never appear on any
and enviable list.
They themselves live in
the world of winners,
the one of people were on the good list
and they know it.
And they never stop doing what winners do,
lecturing losers on what they have to do.
Feel-good books are
part of this lecturing.
If this magazine's request annoyed me,
it was so because my first question was,
why ask me that.
Was it by any chance because they thought
that Disturbance was a feel-good book?
I began my reply to the journalist
who had written me by saying
that I would ask my physician
to draw up this list in my place.
Because after all,
what they were asking
for was a prescription.
Nothing is easier for me than
to obtain a prescription.
Since the attack, I have been
surrounded by physicians.
Like more years imaginary invalid.
If one of them isn't the available
to write a prescription for me,
another will do it.
My physicians don't refuse me anything.
They are attentive,
generous.
In exchange,
they get my discipline and my gratitude.
That I had it.
You know how they are.
At least in France no one
can read their writing.
You would think they write
like certain authors do
so as not to be read.
As if they preferred
obscurity to misunderstanding.
when the patient enters our office is
because he feels sick.
When he comes out and
read the prescription
before going to the pharmacy,
he feels stupid or illiterate.
Fortunately the pharmacist
is used to the physician
and knows how to decipher
his hieroglyphics
So I told the journalist
that if he wanted to decipher the list
of feel good books drawn
up by my physician,
you would probably need the help
of an expert in physiology
or a pharmacist.
And I said to myself,
saved. They won't persist.
But since I am a journalist,
I should have known what
most periodicals are like.
My correspondent immediately replied
that he liked my answer
and would be delighted to
have me develop it freely
but please no more than 300 words.
He was right.
Prescriptions are supposed to be short.
Too much medicine leads to intoxication.
But what feel-good books,
was I going to ask my
doctor to put on the list?
And which of my doctor should I ask?
My personal surgeon,
the other surgeons who treated me,
one of my physical therapist?
At the hospital in January 2015,
my first physical therapist
had advised me to read Tom
McNab's Flanagan's run.
This is a story of a man
who during The Great Depression
organized a race on foot
across the United State.
Despite difficulties and setbacks,
several competitors came
to know one another,
like one another,
how to do one another,
everything hard ends well.
I quote a summary
because I never read the book.
If I understand correctly,
this book is an optimistic counterpart
of Horace McCoy's novel,
"They Shoot Horses, Don't They?"
Where everything hard ends badly.
This novel, I did read.
I also saw the film that
Sydney Pollack made of it
starring Jane Fonda.
But I didn't watch it
all the way to the end.
I must have been 10 or 12 years old
and my parents sent me to bed around 9:30.
The next morning I asked
my mother to tell me
how the film ended
and she told me that Jane Fonda died.
I was traumatized
and to this day I've
never seen the film again.
The novel by McNab, a former athlete
dates from 1982
that of Michael McCoy,
a former journalist,
from 1935.
I imagine that the first novel,
the one I didn't read
uses The Great Depression
as a historical framework
in which the experience
and optimistic message of the athlete,
the winner can be developed.
In the second novel
there is no such message.
The Great Depression is
not a historical framework.
McCoy experienced and
underwent it directly.
Writers who have been on the losers' side
that is on the side of
an excess of reality
don't write feel-good books.
They know that Jane Fonda dies at the end.
Three years later,
the same physical therapist
resumed treating me
again in her office.
In the meantime I had
started running again
despite my missing fibula,
the one that now serves
as my lower jawbone.
The physical therapist told me
that she also run with her dog,
a Cocker Spaniel named Happy.
One of the first question she asked me was
"Have you read Flanagan's run?"
I almost say yes
but I was afraid she
would ask me to elaborate,
tell her what I thought of the novel
while she was massaging my cheeks and jaw.
So I preferred to tell the truth
and I said I still hadn't bought it.
At my next visit she gave me a copy.
She regularly asks me
whether I've read it.
It's in my library
between the books of Thomas McGuane
and those of Robert McLiam Wilson.
Two very pessimistic novelists
that I have read.
But I still haven't opened Flanagan's Run.
So, I couldn't put it on the list
that the magazine was asking me for.
Which book should I put on the list?
To answer that question,
I first had to ask
another more specific one
to which I've just began to reply.
What is a feel-good book?
It wasn't possible to answer
that question in 300 words
so in my response to the magazine,
I wrote about other subjects
including a writer I like
who so far as I know never
what a feel-good book
but whose works have
nonetheless greatly benefited me, Nabokov.
Before continuing my response
here in more than 300 words,
I have to admit as you
have no doubt understood
that I don't like lists.
They always seem to be intended
to empower those who make then
and to exclude or make uncomfortable
those were not on them.
They remind me of our ceremonies at school
and even of the smell of
the cafeteria of the school
another of cauliflower and bechamel sauce.
But not being the editor of a newspaper
I have never dreamed of awarding prizes
and I have no nostalgia about school
not even olfactif.
My memories of the classroom are
neither good nor bad.
They are simply mediocre and gray
like the student that I rapidly became
after middle school.
I was particularly fond of
dancers and troublemakers.
The ones who didn't make me feel good,
the feel bad guys.
I didn't understand why
I wasn't very smart.
But it seemed to me
that truth was on their side
on the side of the discomfort
that they spread around
themselves and in me.
This discomfort was not without charm,
without danger
and without loneliness.
It led me to do stupid
things to is isolate myself
to have disagreeable
and unpredictable moods
that were unexpected even for me.
And also to expose myself
to all kinds of reporters
first of all my own.
I believe that I truly began to read
after this discomfort
and in the loneliness
to which it gave rise.
It was this discomfort that helped me
to understand Rimbaud, Proust, Kafka
and quite a few other writers.
That is how my feel-good books came to be.
There are books that have allowed me
to overcome discomfort by exploring it.
They have been my unknown friends.
These unknown friends were guides
like Sergeant Tyree,
the army scoot in Indian Territory in
"She Wore a Yellow Ribbon",
John Ford's western.
Sergeant Tyree is young
but no longer as young as he used to be.
He is courageous, ironic,
always reserved.
He's a contrary of a Miles Gloriosus,
a know-it-all or a blabbermouth.
He's a former Confederate soldier
who now works without
scruples or hesitations
for the Federal Army.
That is his former enemies
because this was the
South lost the civil War.
When I was a child
I preferred the Confederate.
I didn't know anything about slavery
or the deep causes of the war.
If I liked the Confederate,
it was because they inspired rich films.
Films that made me dream.
And precisely because they lost.
I liked the Confederates
and I like the Indians.
Without realizing it,
I liked the losers.
They dreamed and they had
an identity like the winners
but they were dispossessed of their dreams
and of their identity.
They had tried out all
the possibilities of life.
The worst as well as the best.
Sergeant Tyree no longer
has any illusions.
He doesn't show off
that he has experience and
he has a sense of duty.
He has the lucidity and
the distance peculiar
to certain phantoms
who are detached from everything
except the job they have to do.
He doesn't have the violence
and bitterness of Ethan Edwards,
the role played by John
Wayne in "The Searchers".
He seems to have understood
that the best we can do is
to remain in the modest position
that work and talent have
allowed us to obtain.
He goes off all alone to
explore the Indian territories,
unknown,
threatening,
marvelous,
hostile lands,
the territories of Death Valley.
And he comes back with
information that he gives
without commentary to
Captain Nathan Brittles,
also played by John Wayne.
When he is asked what he thinks
of what he has seen,
he smiled slightly
and answers,
"That aint my department, sir."
Naturally Captain Brittles knows as we do
what Sergeant Tyree thinks
and even that he is right
because is the first.
The only person who has seen the reality
of life in this territory.
And because he is intelligent
but except for one time when
the captain gets irritated
he offers no interpretation
of what he has observed.
He is not afraid,
he doesn't complain
or comment
or judge.
Neither does he say what he escaped.
He returns impact Babel
from the enchanted and
funeral land of Death Valley.
I dream of being able to
conclude each of my stories
at the moment when a judgement,
an interpretation is expected
with these words,
"That ain't my department, sir."
The feel-good books in my life have
almost all been Sergeant Tyree's
but I understood that only when
myself returned from Death Valley
with a shattered jaw bone
and with an heck wounded hands
riding behind the Herod with my hands
around his waist like a child
so I wouldn't fall.
My feel-good books written as he does
now with me from unknown,
threatening,
marvelous
and hostile lands.
Sometimes they give me
information with a slight smile,
Something precise and mysterious
that makes me want to go to
or return from the place
from which they come whatever the cost.
Sometimes they find me and save me
when I'm wounded,
lost in the middle of the desert
and surrounded by hostile Indians.
As those who have read Disturbance know
I had essentially Three Sergeant Tyrees
during my nine months of
adventures in hospitals.
Thomas Mann, "Magic Mountain",
Kafka's "Letters to Milena"
and Marcel Proust, "In
Search of Lost Time".
They were scouts or saviors
sometimes both at once.
At no time did they give
me certainties or receives.
They gave me neither good news
nor a happy end.
They held up countless mirrors
to my own life.
But unlike Rita Hayworth
in "The Lady from Shanghai"
I don't think I shattered
in their reflections.
On the contrary they allowed me
to detach and concentrate myself.
They helped make me in part
at least Sergeant Tyree.
Of course I'm aware that most people
especially here in America
a feel-good book is
something very different
from the silhouette and
taciturn personality
of Sergeant Tyree.
Usually, it is a book of good will.
A book of initiatory propaganda.
It recounts a test,
physical or moral
that has been undergone
and overcome by the author
who comes out of it stronger,
happier and more intelligent.
Or in any case who
presents himself that way.
At the same time,
it gives its distressed readers
a few tips on how to cope.
These tips are easy to follow,
a choice guide to survival.
There is no feel-good
book without a happy end.
It's Flanagan's run written by a coach.
At the end of the book
as at the end of a play
the coach returns to
the stage one last time
to thank his wife, children,
friends, publisher,
grandmother, cousins,
colleagues, country
and even God
without whom he would not be
today's Marvel's person he has become.
And whom success along
with his customers awaits.
In short it's a fairy
tale set in a gymnasium.
When I was in the hospital
my companion Gabriela
absurdly wanted me to
read this kind of book
because that's what she did
when she wasn't feeling well.
She didn't understand how I could read
for example,
"In Search of Lost Time".
Two years before the attack,
I had read passages from the novel to her.
Passages that were quite funny
to amuse her and make her
feel the power of style
and the absurdity of life.
She didn't understand what
pleasure one could take
in reading about solitude,
misunderstandings,
jealousies, lies, sufferings
and nasty unhappy and
ridiculous characters.
I didn't keep trying
what would that do.
Gabriela from Chile but she
had been living in New York
for such a long time
that she seemed to me
to have lost the vital sense
of irony and melancholy
in such a hot city
where everyone seems
to think it is possible
in spite of everything
to survive and to survive and win.
Real feel-good books are
probably a necessity.
So she gave me several
several of them, all American.
She arranged even for me
to meet the author of one of them.
A man who had been badly burned.
We had breakfast with him
in a cafe in North Carolina.
I had ordered an omelette
because it was easier for
me to eat at this time.
Nevertheless, bits of egg were falling
on my trousers as he talked.
"The future belongs to us you know."
I wiped my chin and forgot it all.
Gabriela also sent me links to videos
in which a woman
who was very famous in your country told
how she had survived some
deadly illness or other.
Was it an accident?
I no longer remember.
I've forgotten her name.
Her act was excellent
and for me terrifying.
It was a kind of stand-up feel-good.
I don't like stand-up.
I had only to read a few
pages of these books,
watch the few minutes of these videos
to feel absolutely depressed.
For me there is nothing worse
when one has been the victim of an illness
or a serious trauma
than reading or listening
to survivors tell you
with a cheerful air,
"Do as I did.
"You'll get over it."
I simply felt like tearing up the book
unplugging my computer,
killing the couches
or disappearing for example into a forest.
Not only did these people
with their self-satisfaction,
their superficial optimism
and their instruction manuals
not help me understand
what I was experiencing.
But I felt that if I spend
too much time with them
I would become definitely stupid.
Since I'm a little corny,
I waited until Gabriela
and I have separated
to throw away these books.
I didn't throw them away
immediately after our separation.
For a year and a half,
they remained on my bookshelf
like foils
or perhaps talismans
that I didn't dare touch.
I think I was afraid they
might take vengeance on me.
You didn't believe in us
so you are going to fail.
There's always a threat in
this kind of feel-good books.
If you don't believe in me they murmur,
"You're lost."
As there other definitions
of feel-good books.
Take for example Madame Bovary.
Emma's use is narrated by Flaubert
at the beginning of chapter six
of the first part of the novel.
Flaubert tells us about the characters
with whom the young woman identified
with whom she felt in accord
and grew up in a convent
and in the purest romantic tradition.
They were born in a best-seller
of the end of the 18th century
and the beginning of the nineteenth
published one year before
the French Revolution.
She had read quote,
"She had read Poland Virginia
"and she had dreamed about
the little bamboo house,
"the nigger Domingo,
"the dog Fidel,
"but above all about the sweet friendship
"of some dear little brother
"who seeks red fruit for you
on trees taller than steeples
"or who runs barefoot over the sand
"bringing you a bird's nest."
Flaubert is ironic as usual
and maybe even sarcastic.
In is work there is almost always
because of the sculpture of his sentences
an agitation between distance and wonder
between beauty and reality.
But in these lines it is
precisely the primary effect
of a feel-good book
as I conceive it that one reads.
It's the reverie
that brings the solitary reader closer
to the characters he is discovering
ends up creating a third person.
A person who is neither entirely real
nor entirely fictional.
A person who like a patient under morphine
calms the pain of existence
and intoxicates herself at the same time.
A person who if she's defenseless
and without information about
the territory she's entering,
about the world in which she lives,
if she has not acquired
Sergeant Tyree's point of view
will inevitably be massacred.
Unlike Emma Bovary I
did not go to a convent
and I did not decide to kill myself
but I'm well acquainted
with the statue of the
author of Paul et Virginie
the novelist and botanist
Bernardin de Saint-Pierre
It stands in Paris, the statue,
in a famous garden
that he helped create
the Jardin des Plantes.
It was the first public place I went to
in January 2015
with my family and friends
when I was living in the
Pitie salpetriere hospital
and preparing myself
from one operation to the next
for the graft of the fibula
to replace my jawbone.
On that afternoon I had a
large bandage on my face,
a cap on my head,
an overcoat that was too
long and too big for me
and on my shoulder
a kind of handbag which
with the help of a tube
sucked up the pews and her oddities
that were coming out
of the hole in my jaw,
the VACS,
Vacuum Assisted Closure System.
My brother took a few photos of me
lost in this overcoat and bandage.
I looked like a ghost.
At this moment,
I too sad I'm a sad person.
Half-way between life
and the imagination of life.
But an imagination that is determined
by the death that this
life has just gone through.
By the deaths that at that time
I found so hard to drive away.
I am floating.
I was the one who asked to visit
this garden of my childhood
quite close to the hospital
where I had to return
to a few hours later.
I wanted above all to
move as slowly as possible
through the greenhouses
where the cactuses are.
I have always liked cactuses
and the warmth of the greenhouses
in which they are found.
when I'm in these places
I feel like I'm eternal
that nothing could
happen to me ever again.
On the way to the greenhouses,
I stopped in front of the statue
of Bernardin de Saint-Pierre.
It is located a few
dozen metre from the zoo
where I also went when I was a child
and which the learned writer founded.
I look at the statue with pleasure
almost with gratitude.
It did me good.
Why?
In addition to his beauty
it has one particularity.
Two levels.
Set on this on his base,
his chin on his hand,
the writer seems to be dreaming
like a melancholic God about his creatures
which are scattered in the
battled earth beneath Him.
He dominates them
because he imagines them.
But is this imagination
leads him elsewhere
toward an idyllic and tragic world.
This world ends in fact
with separation solitude and death.
Back on the island of Mauritius,
Virginia drowns in a shipwreck
and Paul dies of sorrow.
Paul and Virginia was an essential book
for generation of readers.
It made them imagine
and love tragic person.
It made them believe
what they were probably
ready to believe
that true love is an
impossibility and a tragedy.
And this impossibility and tragedy
were precisely what fed the
desire to experience that love
to experience it all the way to the end.
Paul in Virginia is
certainly a feel-good book.
There was a genuine enjoyment
in experiencing desperate love.
In soaking one's heart in
an exotic and morbid liquor.
Enjoyment is not as you know,
necessarily incompatible
with masochistic reverie.
I looked with gratitude at the statue
of Bernardin de Saint-Pierre this day
and his infortunate creatures.
Literature could include the situation
that I was reading through
and inspire the feelings that
I had decided to experience.
It could above all led me to explore them.
I left Paul and Virginia to their sad fate
in order to return to the hospital
and after visiting the
greenhouse with the cactuses.
To Death Valley and Sergeant Tyree.
I come now to two final questions.
The evening of the day
when the magazine asked me for the list
of my feel-good books
I said to my wife with annoyance,
"Why are they asking me that.
"Why me?"
She looked at me surprised and replied,
"Well because you wrote a
feel-good book. Didn't you?
"You may not have wanted to write it
"but for most of your readers,
"that's what you did.
"Whether you liked it or not,
"you did them good.
"At least that's what they'll tell you."
Still more annoyed I said,
"But I didn't give any receipts
"and there is no happy end at all.
On the contrary,
the book ends on November 13th 2015
the day of the attack of the Bataclan.
I was in Manhattan.
I could hardly stand.
I could hardly stand up,
I had the feeling that the
ghosts of the Twin Towers
were rising to collapse again.
I no longer knew what
world I was like living in.
My surgical reconstruction
was far from finished
and as if that were not enough
I left the last word to my surgeon
who told me to put off by return to France
as long as I could.
My wife replied still more calmly,
"It's not a happy end
"but it tells the story of
a successful reconstruction
"of a battle that you waged won.
"you didn't need to give
receives for people to feed them.
"On the contrary it's precisely
"because you didn't give any
"that you did them good."
I thought about the letters
I had recived
that I was still receiving.
There were a hundred of them.
They now fill two whole boxes,
one in the cellar
the other under my bed.
I opened the boxes and we read
what had been written to me.
Most of the letters came from patients,
former patients,
caregivers,
former caregivers.
In a country like France
where the medical system is still strong
and socially so important,
that includes a lot of people.
One patient had given my
first name to the drip stand
with which she moved
all around the halls of her Hospital.
Women gave my book to their
sick children or husbands
so that it might accompanies
them like a Vietcong.
And when the children or husband died,
they reread the book to find them alive.
You might perhaps ask,
why is he talking on you
about female readers?
The answer is simple,
it is primarily women who were reading
at least in France
and in any case have read my book.
In the world where I spent three months
I also learned that many patients
now had my book on their bedside tables.
My surgeon told me that
she sensed in this demand
even complain,
"Take care of us the way
you took care of him."
And to tell the truth,
I understood them
because I had always thought
that the attention given me
should have been the rule
and not the exception of the system.
That the patients were most
held out my book to my surgeon.
Who was I addressing then?
The person she was
or the character on paper she had become?
One reader also sent me the diary
he would I would kept at the time
that he was reading Disturbance.
Nothing about his family life
and his private life
was Eden from from me.
I learned everything about his wife,
his children,
their habits,
desires and conflicts.
I accompanied them even to bed
and in their lovemaking.
Sentences I had written
appeared very regularly.
They had entered into his life
and when he had problems
in return to them
not as solutions
but as crutches.
I was disturbed by this journal.
And more generally by
the excessive intimacy
of some of the letters
because so I had written an intimate book.
It seemed to me that I had done
so in such a way
that the writing itself
put a certain distance.
Everything it brought closer
to the awareness of readers.
It was an intimate book
but I hope at least that it
was not an indiscreet book
nor one that authorized indiscretion.
Also I did not want to allow readers
to enter my life indiscreetly.
Neither did I want to enter
indiscreetly into theirs.
Once readers finished the books
I would have liked them
to say with a slight smile
like servant Sergeant Tyree
when he returned from Indian Territory
"I saw this,
"I experienced that,
"but so far as commentary is concerned,
"It ain't my department, sir."
Then I made my little
inventory of the novels
that in France are connected with illness,
trauma
and death with medicine.
There were of course
the novels of narratives
that arose from the first world war.
Many French writers were physicians.
I suddenly realized
that in the last 10 years
two bestsellers had been set
at least in the world of the hospital.
D'autres vies que la mienne,
lives other than my
own by Emmanuel Carrere
and happily live oh
Mend the Living, by Maylis de Kerangal
The former is a nonfiction book,
the latter, a novel.
The first book deals
with a two-fold tragedy.
That of a family whose
child has been the victim
of the tsunami in Sri Lanka
at a time when the author was with them.
And that of a woman
that had a sister-in-law
with dying of cancer.
What connects the two stories
is a presence of the writer
an active witness to
these dramatic events.
The second book becomes
a tragedy of family
whose child has been in a car accident
that has left him brain dead
and whose heart is to be
transplanted into another patient.
What connects these two families
experiencing a tragedy is the hospital
and the graft of the dead onto the living.
I had read and like both these books
long before the attack on Charlie Hebdo
but it hadn't occurred to me
to reread them afterward.
I hadn't even thought about them.
Both relate a collective
experience of tragedy.
They tell how individuals survive death
or survive with death
by struggling and in one way or another
by coming together.
Then I saw without wishing to
I had done the same thing.
I had recounted the story of a man
who was a victim of a terrorist attack
and who fights to pull through
but also the story of various
groups of family members,
friends, co-workers and hospital staff
whom this attack upset
and were fighting to
help him pull through.
In this sense each of us
had written feel-good books.
What one woman friend of mine
has called, referring to readers
of a Emmanuel Carroll's book,
"Men of goodwill."
Les Hommes de bonne volonte,
Men of Good Will, was
precisely the title of a
series of great French humanistic novels
published in the thirties.
It was written by a former
physician Jules Romains.
What differentiated my book
from those of Kerangal and carrere was
among other things the point of view.
The story of Disturbance
is recounted exclusively
from the point of view of the person
who experienced it.
I am servant Tyree,
but I am also the wounded man
he put behind him on his horse
and whom he saves by giving him first aid
and then by the slow gallop of the text.
A little more than 20 years earlier
in 1990, another book
that had a great success in France
recounted the story of illnes and death
connected with AIDS.
Herve Guibert, To the Friend
Who Did Not Save My Life.
I had read it when it came out
and it had marked me.
It's a funny, aggressive,
sly, angry book in which the author
who is like is the patient is constantly
in a state of mistreat and effective war
against everyone.
His entourage,
his caregivers.
He's an individual who
is fighting ungraciously
and without illusions
to obtain informations and rights
that are not being given him.
All that he thinks are
not being given to him.
This individual is a product
of a world and a culture
in which the power of the gaze
the presence of the body
and a certain paranoia
peculiar to intelligence,
dissolved morality,
good feelings
and everything that was called humanism.
Guibert's book was thus in
no way a feel-good book.
But it made history.
Carrere and Kerangal's book
along with my own came
out in another time,
twenty years later.
I think that in themselves
they I did not bring any good news
but perhaps in spite of everything
they did provide good feelings
that are not found in Guibert's book.
In those who are marked by a violent
and transgressive
individualism and by heads
or more exactly they brought
a kind of consolation.
Consolation is neither healing
nor illusion
nor a method intended to make
us better or simply healthy.
It's rather rough caress
given the misery of the world.
it's longer requires tongue transgression
but it does require confidence
and to a certain extent
the spectacle of reconciliation
in order to live in a world
that provides hardly any at all.
Is it humanistic caress?
If it is,
have I really written a feel-good book?
It is art form in conclusion to reply.
We are seldom good
analysts of our own books.
I can simply say that at the hospital
without truly thinking about it,
I made Proust's, Kafka's and Mann's books.
My feel-good books.
Books that were returning from unknown,
threatening,
marvelous
and hostile lands.
They didn't hide from me
anything they had seen.
But better yet,
they didn't hide from me
anything that I experienced.
And they have rejoined
without commentary
and with a slight smile
that endless territory, my library.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank You so much.
We have a little time for some questions.
And the microphone,
come down with the microphone.
We would like to have a few questions.
Please, don't leave the stage.
- [Alice] Thank you Philippe.
It's my pleasure to break the ice.
I have two questions really
and one is,
why do you think it's
women who are reading now?
And the second question may be related.
It's, you're setting up some boundaries
between confessional literature
and a kind of discreet
but intimate literature.
And I wonder how you
conceive of that intimacy.
- Thank you Alice.
The first question
I don't know because I'm not
a sociologist of literature
and you know in Paris
there is a big subway.
I always take the subway.
And it's a subway as in a train.
You can see that at least in Paris,
who is reading a book?
A woman, most of all.
It's very difficult now
because
I think
we will see later
when the relationship
between men and women change
into the world if it's going to change.
But as far as I know,
I'm a man of my age, 56.
I think that many women
of my generation I knew
they have
more access to interior life
because they had less
access to public life
and so they had this interiority
led them to be more sensible
to the stories I read.
It is a very desperately
classical response
may be old-fashioned
but that's why I would
be very curious to know
what will happen in the
regeneration coming.
I hope of course just as men as women
would read,
you go out all the time
I can check now
it is still the women who are reading
at least in the public spaces.
And the second question
I'm not sure I understood well.
The separation between nonfiction and,
(lady mumbles)
I think the only answer can be personal
and the fact is as a reader,
I prefer intimate tales
and I don't care if they're
fiction or nonfiction.
I mean last summer I
was reading Middlematch.
and of course I loved it.
And for me I don't make any difference
between Middlematch
and the great personal
nonfiction book, you know.
These are characters
and I actually I wrote my book.
Everything is real in a sense
that it is everything I experienced.
And there is no lie at all.
And I don't write in this book a sentence
about things I didn't directly experience.
But I composed it as a novel
in the sense that it is
a tale with characters.
And I was speaking in my conference
about my surgeon Chloe.
She is now a very famous
character in in France.
Interviewed on TV and radio and so on.
And it is very strange for her
more than for me
because, who is she?
Is she the character I created in my book
which is only from my point of view?
Of course when she asked she says,
"No.
"I'm another person.
"I'm not the person he describes."
But on the other way
she knows she is this person
and now she will be as
far as the books arrive.
She is this person.
So she's the character
and this is the special
part of the nonfiction.
she is the character
and she's a real person.
And I can tell you it's very strange to,
and from time to time we are together
in a kind of show.
And I never know to whom I'm speaking to.
And who is answering
and because now, of course
she still my surgeon
so she's supposed to work on me
in the months coming again, a bit.
And so, of course I have
to kill the character
to go back to the surgeon.
And she has to kill the writer
to go back to the patient.
- [Man] Yes, thanks so much
for sharing your story with us
for the inspirational talk.
Can we now define feeling good
or feel good
as the struggle of recognizing adversity,
facing it head-on
and working together in community.
Doctors, nurses, physical therapists,
friends and family to overcome it
and triumph you know,
one adversity at a time.
Is this what you're trying to define?
- Yes.
I think,
in a way Yes.
Feel-good is that
I mean what is important is
I told that I hope at
the end of the conference
is that the fact that a group,
different group of persons
not only helped me to recover
help the victim that it was me,
it could be another one.
But they helped themselves
helping the victim.
And that helping means they think,
they act,
they talk to each other
and they change.
And by doing all that,
life is coming back to a place
where death was invited.
And
if I am reluctant
to the idea of feel-good book and so on
is because
you can never generalize
and treat as a writer to,
you can't generalize an experience.
You can tell an experience
but it's very difficult to think
that what works for me
will work for you
or for another one.
And as a writer however
and the great reader of novel,
the novel is a great novel it is really,
always the story of a group of person
and a group of person in a society
but these are individuals.
The great novelists won't
give you any receives
of the way how to recover and so on.
He tells you,
this guy in recover this way
and it tells a story
and this guy he failed.
And this is a reader
one who experienced this
and with this after a while
to think about his own life
but you won't find any
solution in the book.
There is no solution.
There is a solution
but only in one life
which is not another life.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Maybe it sounds pessimistic.
For me it's not pessimistic at all.
It's optimistic.
It means we are free
to read whatever we want to read
and then we are free to find our way in
what happens to us
in a certain limits, of course
because when the disasters
are falling on us
it's very difficult to feel free.
But then you can fight
and find your own way
to feel free.
I found my own way
strangely in the hospital.
It was very very tough
but I like the hospital
because for me,
I think I was at my best
when I was in the hospital.
It is it may be very strange
but I can assure you it was a moment
I had the best I can do
not only for me but for others.
I think I gave it
when I was in the hospital.
And then I tried to give it again
in another way like writing.
But that writing is my is my job
since 35 years
so it's different.
- [Gary] I will address a question to you
that is coming a little bit
out of left field perhaps
but we were talking in my
office before you spoke
about the importance of
music in your recovery
and your listening to music
and somebody giving you a gift
of well, you,
It was Bach in particular
that you listen to
somebody gave you a gift of
over 200 cantatas of Bach
that's a lot of listening.
And I'm wondering if
somebody had approached you
and asked you,
"Sent me a list of feel-good music."
Would you have felt the same ambivalences
and even anger about such a question?
- It's a good question
and we usually say it's a good question
when we have no the answer.
But I'll try to find the answer.
Let's take an example
let's think about the one
was very important to me
when I was precisely
in the hospital, Bach.
Because it was like a ritual for me.
I tell about that in the book.
I would listen to Bach,
most of all how do you say in English
(foreign language)
A piano
and several versions.
So was it a feel-good music?
I don't believe in God
but Bach
made me doubt not about the fact
that God would exist
but that something existed
because I was really feeling
that he was through his music
kind of peace was falling in my room.
And not on me in my room
but in in the block too
when I was going to the block
because what happened is step by step
people from the hospital
I mean carer, surgeons, nurses
they would listen to Bach too
and I tell one that I write to the block
and these days it wasn't
my Chloe my surgeon
but another surgeon
who is now a friend actually
and he put some Bach
before he made me sleep
in the block so I was really in the,
before the operation.
And he told me,
"I guess you don't know
this interpretation."
And so he had looked for him
and so it was a kind of
feel-good music for all of us
but as it that sense to say
that Bach is a feel-good music.
Is much more than that
because on another way it tells you
doesn't tell you makes you feel that
even if you are suffering a lot
and you are absolutely
entitled to complain whatsoever
there is something in
this music that tells you
that the best you can do is
to be silent,
to be quiet.
And because there is something stronger,
deeper coming from I don't know where.
And will pass who is music
and I could really feel this
because it's unusual to listen to Bach
in such a hospital.
People usually they watch TV.
And not good TV.
And I understand perfectly
why they do that.
It's like a drug.
And like do people in jail.
Of course I think it's a very bad drug
will put you
to depression
but Bach was calm
and so even it was a way for me
to attract,
to bring the nurses and
surggeon to my place.
They would like my place
because there was this music.
So it was feel-good music for them too.
- [Alice] I was wondering
if you could speak
to the topic of satire.
- To the?
- [Alice] To the topic of satire
and whether or not that has a place
in a feel-good book
or as part of your recovery
or just if your relationship to satire
in general has changed?
- I don't understand the word satire.
Satere or to satire?
Oh yes. Okay.
Satire.
I take advantage of you to forgive you
for my very bad pronunciation.
As you know
I'm still working in
this satirical newspaper,
Charlie Hebdo.
And so this satirical newspaper is
most of all a newspaper of cartoonists.
And I'm not a cartoonist.
But I used to know them,
to be with them,
and to live in their mood.
So,
I suppose if I decided
to work for them 15 years ago
It is maybe because the satire was part of
what I like in life
because I think simply its for me.
and then what I say it's always for me
because I think
it helps me
to face problems and disasters.
And I think really it
help people from Charlie
to face these disasters,
this massacre.
I mean the survivors, of course.
And because we always made fun.
Even in the hospital,
I was with wounded friends
and we always made fun
about what happened to us
and about us as patients.
Bad jokes,
I can tell you because they were very bad.
And this was a therapy.
The book is not at all a therapy.
The book is a creation
that this kind of bad jokes we had,
this presence of satire was very important
because precisely,
satire is to laugh
about what is not funny
and to turn it in a way
makes it funny.
That is a sense of satire.
(Audience applauding)
Thank you.
(gentle music)